ils vont nous sous-traiter mec nous voulons juste
nous asseoir et obtenir plus de
sauce de qualité oh s'il vous plaît levez-vous il est intéressé
vous savez qu'il est ma chambre pour six de plus
ici même pour la graisse perdue vos cheveux
mais bientôt Emily montrerait après saké vous
pouvez  tout à l'arrière du paquet avec
le reste de l'âge d'Afrique me manque
mademoiselle Augusta tu descends de ce bus
ne reviendra pas
Je me suis réveillé ce matin soit en sentant que cela
pourrait être une bonne chose que tu as
pris ce bus toute l'année  tu n'as jamais
dit de mots que je ne voyais pas quand je
te parlais je ne te déteste pas c'est
tout ce que tu taquines et ça ne se passe pas [ __ ] de
visite c'est comme le pire jour de ma vie
j'aimerais creuser pour le  toute l'année
entre tout le monde dans ce bus comme de la merde
et maintenant je suis le prochain à être le nouveau
meilleur ami
prends ça
ce n'est pas six drapeaux ce n'est pas un moment qui
passe
profite de ton fils
toi